Did you do that carnivore diet thing?
Did you try that out?
No.
You did.
No,
no.
I like me,
but I didn't do the cardboard that you were going to do it for a certain amount
of time and test it.
Thought about it too much of a foodie.
I like,
what I did was I tried to eat Ribeye steaks every night for dinner,
so I did like a 33% carnivore diet,
but there was a study actually that came out,
it was just like two days ago on that Tmao the sugar that is associated with gut
damage when you're eating a high red meat diet,
right.
When your body takes excess protein and it turns it into sugar,
With theoretically the idea of being that that might be present because your
microbiome is imbalance from a diet that's too heavy and meat.
Is there a microfiber?
It's,
it's because you're buying them.
I thought it was just because of glucogenesis because your body has nothing but
meet your body.
Turns it into glucose.
No,
that that would be something different.
That that conversion of glucose is a different sugar than the Tmao.
Tmao is,
is that's going to be present if you aren't getting enough fiber or if you're
buy on Amazon balanced.
But what this study a couple of days looked at was people who were eating like a
fish and egg and plant rich diet and they had high levels of Tmao too,
but they weren't deleterious.
They're actually as of tech because they had the fiber.
Yeah,
and I mean you could do,
you could do a carnivore diet if you are there.
There's a few populations that do this.
Like in,
in Spain,
I forget the name of the sausage,
but they'll like eat the elite,
the ruminant,
like delete the intestine of the ruminant and get their grasses and their fibers
and their plants literally by eating the stomach of the animal.
But like a cat.
Yeah.
And it's the same issue with like a [inaudible] too much of the amino acid
methionine from just eating red meat would be deleterious.
But if you're getting glycine and some of these other amino acids,
if you're reading like nose to tail,
bone marrow,
bone broth,
all the organ meats,
you know,
head cheese,
Braunschweiger,
just like all of these different mixes of meats.
I think that would be the way to do a cardboard diet.
Yeah.
This is a lot of people that are proponents of that as well,
and then there's a bunch of people that are,
you know,
it's interesting because you've got to,
there's a disparity between the anecdotal accounts of health and wellbeing and
then blood work.
The blood work these folks get is not impressive.
You mean the people on the cardboard?
Yeah.
What I've seen,
I haven't seen anything where I see all their inflammatory markers down their
testosterone up.
I haven't seen anything where it's looking really good.
Yeah,
to High Blood Glucose is another thing that you see what I should say that there
haven't been a lot of tests done.
It's not,
a lot of people are publishing stuff on it,
but the anecdotal evidence is amazing.
It's like it's really weird.
Like my friend Jordan Peterson,
he's had a tremendous success with it,
lost a lot of bodyweight.
He says he's in his intellectual prime.
You said he's never felt better in terms of his energy levels and that guy is,
he is so rigid and disciplined with it,
always eating his meat with salt on it and he drinks water.
And that is slowly,
well,
if you think about it,
it's an elimination diet.
Yeah,
right.
Just like an autoimmune diet.
Or you can say,
well,
you know,
I don't know what's giving me trouble,
soy or wheat or dairy or what have you,
so I'm just going to stop eating all that stuff and switched to primarily meet.
The problem is that it's,
uh,
you know,
I,
I don't want to call anybody out and,
and,
and call them lazy,
but it's almost like kind of a very easy lazy s approach because rather than
figuring out how to do,
you know,
like that,
that sourdough bread,
it's slow fermented.
The Rye and the wheat are in there,
but all the fight of acid that would normally inhibit your ability to absorb
minerals is pre digested by the lacto bash list and all the bacteria in the
wheat.
So you've got a bread that's lower in a glycaemic index and it's,
it's more easily digested wheat,
Rye,
and sourdough or more health.
Right?
And you put the Ryan it because it lowers the glycemic index.
And then you've got the,
um,
uh,
what's it called?
The,
uh,
the,
I forget the term.
Uh,
it's a,
it's like a gluten digesting enzyme that gets activated with the lacto
Bachelor's.
So that's a smart bread.
I mean,
it takes fricken 24 hours to,
it's not 24 hours,
but it's like 15 minutes over 24 hours that it takes to make it.
That's an intelligent approach to food preparation,
right?
That's the way that our ancestors or many of the blue zones would have treated
their foods fermenting,
soaking,
sprouting,
slow food.
And you can take a lot of these things that would result in,
you know,
you're talking about Jordan Peterson,
I know his daughter does this as well.
And mckayla Peterson,
they use that elimination diet,
you know,
which is the carnivore diet to clear up a lot of those autoimmune issues.
But you could also just render food more digestible or switch to an elimination
diet or an autoimmune diet for eight weeks or 12 weeks,
something like the Carnivore Diet,
heal the gut,
and then return back to a more all inclusive eating pattern that allows you to
eat,
you know,
dairy,
wheat plants,
et cetera.
All these things that would normally damage the gut if the gut is actually
leaky.
So what are the,
like what,
what's the process like?
What is happening when they go on this very strict elimination diet and they're
just eating meat?
Like what is happening to their gut that allows them to have all these pretty
pretty significant health benefits,
a lot of loss of weight,
increase of energy,
autoimmune issues like Jordan had some,
um,
some pretty significant gum issues.
Those all went away depression that went that way.
But some of that,
some of the gum in the joint stuff might be just as much related to the fact
that he's getting a shit ton of college and you know,
five or I or I,
or not fiber,
but,
and you know,
Elastin and muscle fiber precursors.
He's getting a lot of protein.
Um,
I don't know.
He's eating bone broth and bone marrow,
but maybe a lot of glycine,
some of these other metabolites.
So part of it could just be more fuel on board to repair muscles or to repair
the joints.
But then the other part of it is that when you eliminate inflammatory products
that you're consuming,
like let's say you're eating whatever,
you know,
Wonderbread and commercial dairy or,
or unfermented soy or any of these things that can actually damage the lining of
the gut.
You're creating an inflammatory scenario.
And I know you're,
you're familiar with the gut brain access and how our gut interacts with our
nervous system via the vagus nerve.
And when you have inflammation in the gut,
that affects neural symptoms,
that affects sleep,
affects intellectual performance.
And then you've also got the autoimmune component.
If you're actually truly allergic to or intolerant to some of those proteins
that wind up in the bloodstream in the presence of a leaky gut,
you know,
plant proteins,
lectins are another one that a lot of people complain about.
Then you create almost like a full body damage scenario.
So the idea is you get rid of all that stuff.
You introduced the carnivore diet and I don't know that there's a lot of
components of the carnivore diet that are actually healing the gut as much as
it's the absence or elimination of the foods that were harming it.
Interesting.
The,
you know,
the,
the bell brothers,
Chris and mark,
do you know those guys?
Yeah,
yeah.
They're take on it is basically they've never felt better and you know,
these are guys that work out very heavily.
The difference between them and Jordan is probably that especially,
you know,
mark is a gorilla.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's powerlifting and you know,
it has been doing that basically his whole life.
These guys are what their take on it is essentially there.
At least the way they think is that most people that are talking about diet,
they really don't know what the fuck they're talking about.
Even though you might be able to look at it on paper and you might have these
ideas about what's beneficial or non beneficial.
Some people are proponents of Vegan Diet,
some people were proponents of you know Paleo.
He's like,
until you are actually physically doing something until you are actually doing
something with that diet and then you report how much better you feel that the
people that are actually training really hard,
those are the ones you should rely on.
And he's saying for him personally,
he's never felt better.
Never been leaner.
Yeah,
and a big part of it,
I mean this just returns to diet,
personalization and customization as a whole.
You know,
we live in an era where you can self quantify pretty easily with genetics and
you can find out what ancestry came from,
what blood markers that you have,
what your gut microbiome looks like.
And I don't think we talked about this on the last show,
but there's this idea of eating according to your ancestry and the concept of
what are called cold spots.
Like areas around the world where people have a genetic susceptibility to have
certain diseases that they don't actually develop.
Those diseases don't actually manifest because of their traditional diet.
Like you look at like the Icelandic population that carries the genes that would
render them more susceptible to something like depression or seasonal effective
disorder,
but their diet is very rich in omega three fatty acids and Dha,
which we know can protect against those disorders in then you take take the
Icelandic population and you uproot them and put them in the context of a
westernized diet and all of a sudden depression and sid manifest.
It's an interesting,
so the same thing for like a Cameroon,
Cameroon,
Africa,
higher than normal risk for colon cancer,
but they're eating a diet that's high in fiber.
Why is it higher than normal risk?
Well,
I dunno,
it's a genetic susceptibility,
but the idea is that that population probably figured out at some point in human
history that if they eat a lot of plants where they eat a lot of fiber,
all of a sudden people don't have as many issues with their colon.
Right.
And then you take that same population again,
strip out the fiber,
put him on a westernized diet,
and you get a large portion of the African American population developing colon
cancer.
That's crazy about the seasonal affective disorder.
And you gotta wonder how would that affect people that live in Seattle,
the Pacific northwest,
that are dealing with constant rain.
I wonder if that would have some sort of an impact on them.
Probably even more if you come from that population.
I mean,
I'm on the Spokane side,
but you know,
I'm,
I'm out in the middle of the forest.
I get Sun for maybe 10 to two and I'm on a north facing slope and I work in
doors a lot of the time.
You know,
I'm typing on my computer,
uh,
blogging.
And so I don't get a lot of sun exposure,
but that's where,
you know,
all these new fangled light panels and head worn light devices and things come
in that were actually developed for seasonal affective disorder that actually
work pretty well just to keep your mood up.
If you're working in doors and you'll get sunlight exposure.